I had two guys calling they work at DNA
testing centers one guy had to quit one
guy still works there he told me forty
percent of the children are not the
man's child forty percent forty percent
he said forty percent somebody it's
usually DNA testing mandatory two
scenarios it's where the woman the
person's getting a DNA test because the
woman claims that is their child turns
out it's not the other one is where the
parent is on the death bed and makes a
confession or they need a health they
need a liver transplant blood
transfusion and the blood type there's
no way that that can actually be the
father so then they find out because of
medical reasons you mean that's not my
father then the father finds out from
that way he said it took such a toll on
him that he could no longer do it
because he would be sitting on the phone
counseling the men and the grown
children
who these women falsely exclusion we see
it on more we see it on paternity court
but yet we say many to be held
accountable